[Musique]
il allie puissance de l'esprit
et maîtrise du corps
[Musique]
le kendo un art martial aussi fascinant
qu'intrigant hérité directement des
mythiques guerriers japonais les
samouraïs c'est un des sports les plus
traditionnels non la ligne directe des
samouraïs il s'entraînait et comme vous
pouvez le faire avec des sabres c'est
compliqué donc ils ont fait des chinois
yang badu ou là où on n'est pas obligé
de tuer véritablement l'adversaire
physiquement mais on le tue aussi
mentalement dans les combats pour
remporter un combat de kendo il faut
toucher l'adversaire avec son chine à un
bateau en bambou seuls les coups portés
à la tête au poignet au torse et à la
gorge sont autorisés ici
[Musique]
mais le point n'est accordée que si le
mouvement est accompagné d'une frappe du
pied et surtout du cri qui annonce le
coup
une véritable quête de perfection de
maîtrise de soi c'est plus qu'un sport
repart aussi un peu dans la vie de tous
les jours avec cette exigence toujours
de faire mieux c'est un art martial donc
il ya une certaine étiquette on se
comprend pas n'importe comment dans le
dojo on respecte l'adversaire
donc voilà tout ça aussi transparaît ont
consciemment dans la vie de tous les
jours
aucune ceinture nous permet d'identifier
le niveau de son adversaire
chacun peut se mesurer aux autres et la
discipline peut être pratiqué à tout âge
dans ce club le plus jeune participant à
tout juste 5 ans
david tu pas le droit de le crier de
delta p&g il ne rate rien comme tout art
martial le kendo comporte une dimension
spirituelle et philosophique que l'on
retrouve dans les saluer méditation qui
ouvre et ferme les entraînements
chaque fois nous en démonstration les
gens sont un peu à peu surpris et puis
ça quelque chose un peu hermétique quand
même marqué on est là on a l'impression
que les gens sautent dessus en criant en
se tapant dessus à coups pas tout c'est
une espèce de l'espèce de rigueur et de
moniales
cent mille personnes pratiquent le kendo
en france dont 70 dans ce club d'orléans
un club qui depuis 40 ans continue de
perpétuer la tradition pour former les
samouraïs des temps modernes
[Musique]